One of the dominant design principles that Android adheres to
Is that it is a multi-tasking operating system.
Users can run multiple applications and can quickly switch between them as needed.
My name is Colt McCannless
In order to ensure that your app is working well,
No matter what other applications do in your device,
It requires little preparatory work and little useful API.
In essence, it is the main cause of the most common tragedies.
In particular, applications work to their own advantage without taking into account the larger environment.
For these applications, this is not necessarily a big problem.
But remember that each running application takes a small portion of limited device resources.
When the total resources start to take effect, the user experience will suffer.
Each running application contains a resource pool that resides in the device memory.
For example its status and the state of the graphics resources. For the most part,
All of the allocated heap objects are in memory
Even when the application is in the background.
Over time, as expected, the memory available in the device will be executed
Because it is consumed by other applications,
You will need to terminate existing applications to free memory for the active application.
Remember that the full reason is that we leave the application in the background in memory
Is to switch between the application in the background and the application located in the foreground
Very fast operation.
But this does not apply to applications in the background that have been terminated.
If your application is terminated and the user returns to it, we have to start from scratch,
This means restarting the application
As if it was not loaded into memory in the first place,
And certainly a much slower process of switching to it than the background.
But the good news is that it is not necessary to end your application.
Instead, when memory becomes limited,
The application can offer some of its allocated space to the system again
In order to avoid the pain of ending.
To facilitate the ritual of this sacrifice of memory transfer, Android offers a set of reverse calls
Which will be released to your app and which you need to respond to.
But first, let's talk about things that happen when things go wrong.
Once all the applications in the background are terminated,
In order to save memory,
The active application on the reverse call will receive low memory,
Indicating that things have become terrible
Which requires the immediate release of any resources in memory
To help stabilize the system.
If you have things in memory do not have a need right now,
This is the time to liberate it.
Unfortunately, this reverse call occurs only after all applications have been terminated in the background.
It would be really nice
That instead of just ending those applications in the background,
They must be allowed to re-edit the mass of part of the memory to the system,
Which would help keep things going but also prevent applications from being terminated.
This is the exact cause of the onTrimMemory reverse call
Filed with IceCreamSandwich version.
This reverse call was issued to all applications running
And gave them the ability to free up memory instead of being exposed to termination.
This is provided by having the correct value given to the inverse call.
The level of decline given to you is between 0 and 100.
But there are also a few known values ​​so you can choose to check on them.
For example, the TRIM_MEMORY_MODERATE value
Means the device is starting low memory.
This is the time for your application
To start expelling objects, such as your temporary memory for a bitmap thumbnail,
While the TRIM_MEMORY_BACKGROUND option
It means that some applications have started to hang in the background
Where an application was recently moved to become an application in the background.
This is the time to start editing memory
This will not be critical if the user returns to your app quickly.
If you compare these values,
You may want to make sure you use a larger comparison of equality,
Only if we add new specific values ​​in the future.
The best part is that in order to help you free up memory from every corner of your application,
This call can be bypassed on the activity, retail and service,
Content provider and application categories.
But in order to produce the best user experience,
Your app should not be just a reaction to writing memory cases
But also proactively, depending on the machine.
The activity manager is dot isLowRamDevice added in KitKat
It can be used to help detect if your application is running
On the device with low memory.
Currently, the true return value usually indicates 512 MB or less.
This condition should be used by applications
To help identify features that may be enabled or disabled
Depending on whether it will be a good user experience for low-memory devices.
Of course, a gentle disposition with the rest of the system is just the tip of the iceberg,
That's why you need to check out the rest of Android's performance patterns
Do not forget to join our community on Google+
To get other cool tips from other developers.
So stay calm, type your code, and always remember, performance is important.